what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video The Avengers slth Illuminati
basically destroyed death so this is the
Thanos series we're currently three
issues into it if you need to get caught
up make sure you click the link to the
end of the video but the long and short
of this is that Thanos appeared on earth
started attacking Fresno California for
reasons that nobody understands all the
while seeking out some particular person
now as we found out at the end of the
last video that we did this was actually
mistress death in human form and in fact
there's a conversation that takes Place
between Thanos and the girl in osbaldos
which it does seem a little strange
they're having this conversation inside
of a taco joint No Stranger Than Thanos
hijacking a truck and chasing this girl
down which is exactly what he did in the
last video but what he does is he tells
her you are the cosmic personification
of death itself now of course this guy
Greg shows up right poor Greg this guy's
about to get it rough
man right this guy like offers him some
food you know like chips and salsa
kitchen's a little slow that kind of a
thing this girl wants like like maishi
wants like the whole entire bottle of
tequila right cuz I mean she's kind of
going through a lot but ultimately
Thanos basically tells her that he was
stuck in a kind of endless Abyss right
just one of the many instances where his
character quote unquote died essentially
and that in that moment he had called
out for death but in realizing what he
was doing he came to the realization he
wasn't looking to die that he was
looking to be embraced by mistress death
and that kind of rekindled the love that
he had for the concept of death now the
reason why that's important is because
in recent years specifically going into
like the more recent eternals run right
that led into Judgment Day Thanos had
not really been the Thanos that we'
known for a while which is to say
basically a simp for mistress death
right being down bad for this chick he
hadn't really been that guy for a long
time this is a way to kind of return him
to his classic form no doubt that's
happening because he's not in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe anymore so Marvel
Comics doesn't have to copy the MCU
version they can just taken back to his
own form but in the midst of this whole
conversation right he says I was lost
hopeless just as you are within this
strange mortal form my mistress but my
fate my very purpose is once again as
clear as the Starlight we will rule this
universe together it is our shared and
sacred Destiny just as it has always
been I strayed from you but I have
returned and in that moment she
literally just lets out this massive
amount of energy right and just kind of
blows Thanos and everything else away
and then takes off she doesn't fully
understand what's going on here now of
course that's the action of mistress
death but in that moment you're
basically met with her mom right who
just shows up on the scene with
basically a hunting rifle and Thanos
just kind of Yanks her up and it's like
what's your bested interest in all of
this she's actually way more important
than you think she is where she seems
irrelevant but she's probably the single
most important person in this entire
story Roberto Marie is technically her
name but as Roberta is like taking off
right just fleeing in this truck the
Illuminati try to stop her and that kind
of thing I do love that Christopher
cwell is doing this if I'm being honest
instead of it just being like some crazy
grandiose stuff or something like that
she's just like driving away in a stolen
truck and like The Avengers are just
trying to chase her down it's what would
happen in the real world if we're being
honest with
ourselves and I really hope we get to
see a scene like this in the MCU at some
point but of course Thanos appears and
just like stands in front of the truck
which basically just leads to this girl
crashing into Thanos the truck gets
totally obliterated and this girl is
effectively dying but Thanos doesn't
really care right he's like let her die
right end this foolish ruse because this
girl can die but mistress death as a
concept cannot now here's one of the
cool things that's going to blow your
mind right I'm I'm I'm about to
absolutely blow your mind out of your
head if you're not aware of this already
in Marvel com Comics there is a being
named anthropomor and what you're seeing
here with the idea of like a physical
body and a cosmic entity that's
basically what he does so so Sidetrack
from this comic for a second and wind
back to quazar issue number 37 back in
1992 and we were introduced to
anthropomor as basically the guy who
runs a place called the dimension of
manifestations the way this works all
the cosmic entities in Marvel Comics are
literally Concepts they're intangible
they can't really be seen they can't
really be felt or they can't really be
touched or anything along those lines
they defy the five senses so in order to
be able to communicate with Mortal
beings that what pretty much all the
cosmic entities do outside of literally
the celestials and galatis they're
really the only exception of this
because they already have physical forms
all the cosmic entities at any point
will go to the dimension of
manifestations and they will be given
what's called an mbody and that in turn
is what they will put their Essence into
now the mbody is all always the physical
representation of that Cosmic entity but
they in turn will appear to a mortal and
they'll talk to them so that's how you
see Cosmic entities they're not actually
it's not really the entities themselves
it's more of just like a housing that
they placed themselves into which is the
reason why beings like Thanos and these
guys can go toe-to-toe with Cosmic
entities and fight them in order to
truly destroy eternity and infinity and
all the cosmic entities therein either
you would need something like an
Infinity go or Cosmic Cube or you'd have
to find a way to destroy the entirety of
the universe itself outside of like
those two things or being a highlevel
reality warper that can manipulate the
fabric of reality itself it's virtually
impossible to destroy the essence of a
cosmic entity but destroying their
physical form yeah man you can do that
all
day right because it's basically like
blowing up a house right it's just not
that hard to do so back into the story
itself as Roberta lays dying mistress
death suddenly manifests right and
that's why as a cosmic abstract she
cannot actually truly be destroyed well
I take that back they did it in Thanos
imperative in the alternate universe
they did that they still never really
gave us an adequate explanation about
how that compares to the main Marvel
Universe but they did manage to actually
destroy mistress death as a cosmic
entity but the fact remains here right
she just kind of lashes out but this is
when you learn what truly went on that
doctor strange approaches mistress death
and says we gave you what you wanted a
human life and a human death now Thanos
responds and saying but in doing so you
have weakened her right you have brought
her down to your level she is a cosmic
abstract Beyond contestation now one
part of this is because Thanos is sing
in a way that I've just never seen right
I mean this guy right like it's it's
pitiful right it's like this is the guy
who's like girl just disrespects him in
the worst way all the time and like he
still sticks around right I mean it's
just it's it's pitiful right it's just
downright pitiful but the response she
gives is they did this because I asked
them to right and that's when it's
really Thanos who brings the mother of
Roberta in and says actually this is the
one who's truly to blame for this entire
situation right this woman Christine
Collins as Thanos calls her and then
what we do is we wind back to some point
in the past and Thanos says this human
found you she challenged you but even
before she arrived you were already in a
questioning State my mistress weren't
you and that mistress death was in
effect going through a kind of
existential crisis what's really cool
here is she speaks into the infinity
well I can't remember how long it's been
since we've seen those things for those
of you guys who don't know what the
infinity well is it's one of the coolest
things the infinity well is a well that
if you ask it the correct question it
will give you an answer and the reason
why I say that why I say it that way is
Because unless you ask it the correct
way it will not answer you right it will
never give you a response and in fact
that's exactly what happens here right
she asked the question why must I still
be why must I continue for always and
the well simply doesn't answer her
because she's not asking the right
question so again the infinity well is
incredibly important here as an example
it's where Thanos learned about The
Infinity Gauntlet in the first place
that he takes all the Infinity Stones
puts them on a gauntlet he'll become all
powerful that kind of stuck the infinity
well knows everything about everything
and so at the end of the day Christine
Collins is brought before mistress death
having basically found a way to sneak
into her reality or to her Dimension
there's a whole story that goes into it
in like the Marvell story and so on you
don't have to it's not important all you
need to know is that she found a way to
the realm of mous death which is not
impossible right that is one thing that
I do want to specify when it comes to
the dimensions of cosmic entities it is
possible especially when it comes to the
realm of mistress death to make your way
there without actually dying the realm
of mistress death is no different than
like Asgard or any of the other nine
Realms from like the Thor and Odin
Mythos or like the realm of Mesto or any
of that stuff right as long as you have
the either technology or magical
abilities to enter into that realm or
just flat out good oldfashioned reality
warping you can travel there right you
can't technically take a ship and go
there unless your ship has a technology
to get you there through breaking
dimensional barriers but still it can be
done right so that's an important thing
to know you don't have to be dead to
enter into the realm of mistress death
but Christine is here because Roberta
was her daughter in the real world but
Roberta died right she ended up passing
away now we found that out very early on
within the story and that Christine is
here because she wants mistress death to
resurrect her now one of the things to
know is that when it comes to the role
of mistress death even one of the things
that she says it's that she is an
observer now that is an important
distinction to understand when a person
dies mistress death doesn't actually
kill them and I've seen that kind of
confusion out there on the internet so I
felt like it was something to clarify
here mistress death doesn't
traditionally kill people if you piss
her off enough yeah man like she'll help
you finish with all your living but
normally she doesn't it's more just the
natural order of things right like
you're walking across the street a car
is barreling down the road it hits you
and you die is it chaotic sure but it
also fits into what was supposed to
happen with you that's one of the things
you know in Marvel Comics there really
isn't any kind of like grand plan for
how everybody's individual life is
supposed to unfold everybody's just
taking it one day at a time right it's
not as though you have the one above all
who's like so here's what's going to
happen with Iron Man and here's what's
going to happen with Wolverine and
here's what's going to happen with
blackbolt he sucks so he's not going to
do anything useful it's not really like
that right instead it's just things
happening in the world and that's it
mistress death is very very close to how
you would imagine the Grim Reaper to be
right that when you die the Grim Reaper
appears and it takes you you to the
afterlife if you believe in such a thing
and that's why Christine says I sought
you out because when she died when
reberta died I saw you there and I saw
you take her away but at the end of the
day mistress death says I will not
restore your daughter if that is what
you wish she is too insignificant to
upset the balance in any way I.E she is
not one of the most popular superheroes
in Marvel Comics so that's not going to
happen now one of the other cool things
that Christopher kwell is toying with
here is the idea a that Thanos being out
there and basically destroying
everything that's his natural role in
the universe You could argue maybe some
concept right a candle like galatis or
something along those lines the reason
why I say that is because he was banned
from the realm of mistress death Dan can
never die right he's been banned from
that realm for a long time in Marvel
Comics so when he dies or when something
happens that destroys him he just ends
up out there in The Ether until he can
find some kind of a way back and so
Thanos is beyond the realm of mistress
death Thanos will always be out there in
the universe laying waste to everything
and destroying everything so again it's
kind of cool when you take the history
of these characters and you sort of look
at what's Happening Here you put it all
together but the bigger thing about this
is that when mistress death tells
Christine I simply just preside I watch
over as things transpire and take the
souls of those who have recently died
into my realm then in turn Christine
call are a coward right she's like you
clearly have zero understanding of the
pain that kind of loss can cause the
Irreplaceable value of Life a single
life is as important as the entire
universe now I would say this probably
speaks more to the relationship between
a parent and a child than anything else
and it's not to say that like husbands
wives boyfriends girlfriends brothers
and sisters and everything else do not
experience love but there is a
difference between any and all other
forms of love and the love between a
parent and a child because that love is
unconditional your parents will love you
no matter what now whether or not
they're willing to bail you out of jail
or anything like that that's a whole
different discussion
folks but they will love you no matter
what it is unconditional but under any
and all other circumstances that love
can and sometimes does fade out there in
the world for any number of reasons and
so I cannot Envision a single parent a
good quality parent who would not
sacrifice the universe and all things
therein to preserve the life of their
child they would go to the ends of the
Earth in order to make that happen so
that's really what Christina is talking
about here and she says you know I was
going to plead if I had to try and
convince you to give me my daughter back
I was ready to beg but now I just feel
sorry for you and mistress death whis
her away and sends her back to Earth and
so what Thanos does in kind of telling
us this story is he says she had
poisoned you enough that I assume you
then sought the help of these dogs those
who would portend to deal with higher
echelons of matters the Illuminati
stooping ever lower you offered them
some cheap bargain in return for what
you desired and so she appears to the
group and she says I want a human life
and a human death now one of the things
that happens Reed hits this right off
the bat and I would say with Reed
Richards and Dr Strange they're really
the only two people here who can
intelligently speak to the higher roles
of cosmic entities for someone like
doctor strange it's because it's Doctor
Strange right you know magic you know
and sorcery you know all that kind of
cool stuff portals in the eye of aoto
and whatnot Reed Richards is just that
smart and having spent so much time with
galatis he's been taught quite a bit
about the workings of the universe the
working of cosmic entities outside of
what he had already explored and figured
out on his own the only other person now
that I think about it that I would add
in there would probably be Adam Basher
just because of his time on the Ultimate
Avengers right the ultimates oh my God
that story was so amazing we'll have a
link to that at the end of this video
because ultimates is phenomenal right
you want to you want to talk about like
a story that just involves the Avengers
and Cosmic entities and like that's it
that story does it man like ultimates is
probably the greatest story that Marvel
was stupid enough to cancel but the
thing here is that they basically deduce
mistress death could do this on her own
right like she could literally just
choose to do this of her own accord now
she responds and saying yes I could like
I'm a cosmic entity I can basically do
anything I want to and she says but
doing so would upset the larger balance
and raise the suspicions of my siblings
right so basically eternity Infinity all
those other Cosmic entities that are out
there and so Doctor Strange says what
you're asking for could be mystically
arranged and so in effect the question
they ask is but if if we do this what do
we get in return right like why is this
worth our time and she says because the
extinction of your world will happen in
your lifetimes but I alone have the
answer to the question that you
undoubtedly have now in response to that
when does it happen and where does it
happen and how does it happen right do
this for me and I will give you the
answers that you're looking for and so
in time they're just kind of like okay
like we'll go along with this because
having the knowledge of when your
world's going to end kind of beneficial
you know what I mean and so she hands
them a picture of Roberta and she says
make me look like her and send me to
Fresno now here's the ironic thing about
this right here's the important thing to
understand about this whether or not
mistress death chooses to do it she is
not technically dead right Christopher
cwell creates a caveat for himself if
mistress death is in effect the Grim
Reaper and those who die are taken to
her Realm by her then if people die out
there in the world is there anybody to
take them anywhere right now this is not
like Secret Wars 2 where the beyonder
had killed mistress death and no one in
creation could die and it's not like the
events of Thanos imperative where the
exact same thing happened and people
lived forever and they ultimately became
corrupted by guys like Shuma gorath
that's not really the case it's not
what's happening here so again it is
interesting and it's not even going to
be for a prolonged period of time right
probably just for a little while because
I have a hard time believing that
mistress death would go to Fresno and
just be like you know what I like it
here I'm going to stay I feel like
Fresno know the only people who ever go
there are people who are visiting there
they run out of money and they're
trapped people who were raised there and
they end up moving back or people who
simply just can't afford to go anywhere
else which given the price of things in
California I imagine the third one is
probably the most common but at the end
of the day Thanos tells her like wake up
right like this is not who you are you
are not some human being living a life
out in Fresno California that's not you
and so mistress death in turn looks to
him and she says Thanos know this I am
not your mistress and I never will be
right you have Disturbed and disgraced
what I sought to understand and for that
I will never forgive you plus your
simping is pissing me off like that's
really what this is right mistress death
came here for a mission a spiritual
journey right an answer to the
existential crisis that she was
experiencing and Thanos with all his
sing screwed it up right so now he done
pissed her off and made her more mad
than she was before and so in turn she
tells Thanos I absolutely Ely hate you I
despise you and she says that mortal had
more courage than you ever did in all
your days pitifully graveling at my feet
you will die here Thanos on this day by
my hand so seemingly this is actually
the event that leads to the destruction
of the world I don't know if it truly
does and I doubt it does but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end because this is dope let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section if you need to get
caught up make sure you click this link
to the phantos playlist or click this
one for the ultimate and I will catch
you all later peace